الحروب مع اسرائيل والانقسام الفلسطيني
الداخلي افضل الى زياده الازمات السياسيه
والاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه في القطاع وجعل
من غزه مدينه معزوله عن العالم
مشكلات غزه كثيره وباتت عصيه على الحل
سكنوا العائلات وسط القبور واحده منها
التي ستكون لها تداعيات خطيره على مستقبل
الاطفال نفسيا واجتماعيا
مخاطرها كتير الكلاب طبعا بتفحص القبور
هان زي ما انتم شايفين
قصه صعبه بس خلاص تاقلمنا الموضوع
بسكن هنا في الاوقاف بنقطع رزقه لانه احنا
ساكنين
بنشربه بناكل وبنتغسل على الاموات فربنا
كيف بده يجازينا ربنا قال ما فيها رزقنا
اول حاجه
عشان هيك احنا
من نجد الحكومه وزاره الاوقاف انه تشوف
لنا حل
لانه احنا سكنتنا مش سكنه مش احنا خلاص
خلص الدور احنا تبعنا احنا لاولادنا ممكن
لو مثلا يجي عريس للبنت ويلاقينا ساكن في
المقبره ممكن لما يرجعش وكتير صارت الا
غير واحد من من درنانك ياخذ البنت